hey guys
welcome back
to westeros this is alt shift x
a live stream to talk about the brand
new just out premiere episode of
house of the dragon the new game of
thrones prequel show
set some 200 years before the original
game of thrones show uh this is about
the targaryens just just being really
uh thoughtful and considerate and and
just really healthy and kind to each
other all of the time um yeah no it's
gonna be messy
and
i'm very excited we're gonna do one of
these live streams every week at
approximately 10 15 p.m eastern time
sundays right after the episode to talk
about what happened what it all means
how it compares to the books to answer
your questions uh and it's gonna be a
lot of fun so like and subscribe thanks
so much for joining us um so this first
episode was like an introduction to the
political situation at this time setting
up the main players giving us a bit of
background
um and i thought they did a pretty good
job of of introducing us to this
different time period you can really see
that there's more of a
budget there's a bit more cgi there's a
bit more spectacle going on uh it was
reported that george r martin
uh the author of the book had requested
several changes uh to correct things
that he didn't like about the original
game of thrones show and one of those
things was colourful heraldry um bright
banners and and all of the sigils of the
different houses and i thought the
tournament scene did a really good job
of showing the splendor of this time
because this is meant to be the
targaryens at their richest and most
powerful it's a time of decadence and
opulence and it's a time of you know
arrogance comes before the fall you know
um
i really enjoyed how rainy's targaryen
um in this tournament scene was was
talking about these knights as these you
know men with with you know hot blood
and and their their angry and their
horny and they're ready for war and
there's all this like pent-up aggression
that is being displayed in this sort of
you know this tournament this this
simulacrum this play of war but you can
see how it's sort of setting the tension
for real conflict coming soon
um thanks for the super chat from atomic
who says glad to see you back thanks for
the super chat from robin stoops so i
think we're going to attempt to go
through this like mostly chronologically
um so i think the first thing we should
talk about is this introductory prologue
scene at the great council of harrenhal
in the year 101 so the main game of
thrones tv show and the main game of
thrones books happened around the years
298 to 301
ac after the conquest of aegon targaryen
which was in the year zero
and this
council happens in the year 101 so 100
years after aegon's conquest and 200
years before game of thrones and
daenerys and jon snow is this event um
so this is all about the king jiharis
targaryen choosing the next king um
because the whole succession situation
with the targaryens up till now has been
like kind of a mess uh it has not been
organized i'll show you the family tree
because it's hard to keep track of
what's sort of going on here here's a
helpful little family tree so
way back in the day the targaryens came
to dragonstone before the doom of
valyria because of the dreams of denis
the dreamer so you know damion and arion
and this whole line of targaryens lived
on dragonstone which is the island of
westeros then this fella aegon targaryen
was like you know what let's conquer the
continent let's burn some blokes with
dragons let's make a throne let's start
a dynasty it'll be great um and and
viserys talked about you know other
motivations that aegon had as well a
prophecy and we'll get to that so then
aegon conquered westeros um and then his
son aenes inherited the throne from him
which is like fine great but aenes was
kind of weak and no one really liked him
and so he died and then when aenes died
his brother maegor the cruel took over
even though any's had children who
should have inherited the throne so
right away like the whole succession
thing has not worked properly and then
maegor died and then jaehaerys king
joharis inherited the throne even though
joharis had elder siblings who had
children so like even jaehaerys's claim
was not bulletproof so like my point is
that it's always been kind of unclear so
far who gets the throne after the king
dies and so that's why jaehaerys held
this big meeting to get everyone
together and say hey
what are we doing here who's gonna be
the next king um and in the books
there's like 14 different people who
could have maybe been the next king
because jaehaerys um and his wife
alisain had a whole bunch of children
he had amon he had baylon daela but he
also had like a bunch of others i was
like 10 of them or something heaps of
kids but for various reasons one or the
other of them weren't included and
weren't um considered for the throne
like his eldest son amon targaryen was
going to be the inheritor of the throne
but he died he was killed by pirates in
a battle and then balon was going to be
the king but then he died of a burst
belly
ate a bad burrito he died um uh and and
you know jahiris chose balon to be the
heir even though amon had the child
rhaenys so she almost should have could
have would have been the queen of
westeros
this is um
rhaenys over here
but they skipped over her because she's
a woman they skipped over her like twice
uh by choosing balon and then ultimately
in this council they chose viserys over
rhaenys so that's why she's called the
queen that never was
um so
there's this precedent that's been set
like for a long time generally men are
preferred over women and there's never
been a female ruler of westeros um
but women are still considered to have
some claim like there's a it's not super
ordered it's not super structured who
gets the king next
and so there's always a certain amount
of uncertainty and that's why it's so
significant that at the end of this
episode viserys chooses rhaenyra his
daughter to be his heir despite the fact
there's never been a female ruler so far
so you know some people might accept
rhaenyra as the year some people might
have different opinions so this is sort
of setting up the conflict of the story
uh thanks for the super chat from
a chernobog who says what's up with him
cutting himself on the throne yeah so
they mentioned that a couple of times
where viserys
uh has these little cuts and these
little wounds on his body like in this
moment he he cuts himself on the throne
so the throne is a symbol of power the
throne is the symbol of being the king
and there are several examples
throughout the story of kings cutting
themselves on the throne like for
example the mad king aerys targaryen the
father of daenerys 200 years later from
now
ares like cut himself on the throne
constantly like he was constantly
they called him king scab because he was
so often cutting himself on the throne
and it's a symbol of the king not being
suited for the throne like if the king
is cutting himself on the throne all the
time they're not handling their power
well it's almost like the throne is
rejecting them there was a previous king
maegor the cruel the uncle of king
jahiris maegor over here he died on the
throne and it's very mysterious how he
died on the throne some people believe
that maegor like accidentally like
tripped and like fell onto the throne
and the swords of the throne like
stabbed him and killed him it's more
likely that someone just killed him on
the throne but like symbolically there's
this sense that maegor was killed by the
throne he was rejected by it because he
was such an unsuited horrible king so
when viserys cuts himself on the throne
it's sort of saying that you know he is
a nice guy he is trying to do
his best but he keeps cutting himself
because he can't handle power correctly
that's what it means metaphorically
um kyle allison thanks for the super
chat he says that alt shift x is a
better youtube channel thanks for the
super chat from rudy uh night king01 in
a super chat says one-on-one fights have
really improved since thrones also paddy
considine is great as always i can't get
the fuzz out of my head when hot fuzz
out of my head when i see him was paddy
constantine hot fuzz i was not aware of
that i need to re-watch that movie um
yeah i thought the fights were pretty
cool i enjoyed uh the fights at the
tournament were pretty cool uh daemon
versus kristen cole is a lot of fun uh i
i i'm surprised that it's like okay to
like oh sorry
i'm surprised that it's okay for people
to just kill each other on the jousting
field like i wasn't aware that that was
like okay to do because like at
tournaments they sometimes have melees
which is like the time when the knights
fight each other and usually they fight
each other with like blunted tournament
swords and things not like sharp blades
that will actually kill each other um
like you're not meant to like kill
people at tony's but apparently it's
like a semi-accepted oh my god it's like
a semi-accepted practice in this case to
just like be killing people um so that's
kind of wild and also like the fact that
damon targaryen was fighting kristin
cole with dark sister a valyrian steel
blade that can slice through armor and
like slice through swords that doesn't
seem very fair why is damon using dark
sister in a in a tournament fight uh
they've sort of upped the violence in
these tournaments uh it seems to me
i mean i guess it's comparable to you
know in game of thrones season one when
the hound attacked uh when gregor
clegane attacked loris and the hound
came in and saved him like that's meant
to be exceptional you're not meant to be
murking people on the tony field thanks
to the super chat from uh diamond dog
who says what are those balls and plates
in the meeting yeah that's interesting
so like in the small council meetings uh
each of the councillors puts a little
stone into a little little stone plate
thing which seems to sort of symbolize
you know i'm here i'm ready for the
meeting uh these little these little
balls that they have uh yeah i don't
know that's an addition i think it's
just a little symbol of just saying hey
i'm here for the meeting um
i'm not sure if it means anything more
than that
uh bill thanks for the super chat who
says does the book cover the entire tv
series yeah okay so house of the dragon
is a tv show based on the book fire and
blood and the book fire and blood covers
like
170 years of targaryen history fire and
blood starts with aegon the conqueror
300 years ago before game of thrones and
it ends at a period sort of after this
conflict that we're seeing now on house
of the dragon so the show house of the
dragon is only based on like
four chapters in fire and blood when
there's like 15 chapters or something in
fire and blood so house of the dragon is
only based on a small section of fire
and blood fire and blood is not a novel
it's not like the other game of thrones
books it's it's a history book that just
sort of gives a brief overview of what
happened without much details so like 90
of the dialogue that you're seeing a lot
of the like characterization a lot of
the details of this story in house of
the dragon are not in the book that they
are details added on to the
broad summary that is given in the book
so you know they have a structure they
have a plan that's what the book gives
uh but the writers are feeling in all of
the details basically
um thanks for the super chat from
malcolm who says viserys's wife was an
aaron why does she have targaryen hair
so viserys's wife is emma aaron and as
you can see on this handy dandy family
tree uh emma aaron is the daughter of
daela targaryen who married an aaron so
emma is herself half targaryen uh so she
is actually viserys's cousin
um that's why she looks like a targaryen
she is half targaryen the targaryens are
very incestuous they often marry their
siblings like you know jiharis married
his sibling viserys's father balon
married his sister uh that's how the
targaryens do it and that's partly
related to like their dragon blood
because it seems as though the ability
to ride dragons is something that's
genetically in the blood of the
targaryens because they come from
valyria the old empire of the
dragonlords so the incest is related to
keeping the blood pure
and the velaryons are also part of that
in the books
thanks for the super chat from andy b
who says how did you find the acting in
the show um i thought there was some
really nice facial expressions i really
enjoyed daemon i thought the damon did a
great job as like a i mean look at that
[ __ ] eating smirk like he is just such a
[ __ ] stirrer such a rabble rouser he he
he's like a sullen teenager or a
rebellious teenager who's just like
acting out for attention i was skeptical
about matt smith being demon targaryen
like i can't get doctor who out of my
mind when i think of matt smith um but i
i think that his performance works for
me so far and i also quite enjoy uh
viserys's performance um paddy considers
performance um i quite liked even just
the moment in the small council when he
his voice broke when he said that you
know all you people are like coming to
pick over the corpse of my wife and
child and like for a moment his voice
broke when he said that line and i
thought that felt really wonderfully
emotional um so yeah i am enjoying the
acting so far and i think the writing
like one of the things that i disliked
about the later seasons of game of
thrones
is that they sort of abandoned the fancy
medieval old-timey language just sort of
the grammar and you know almost like
shakespearean stodgy language like it
doesn't sound like modern language
whereas towards the later seasons of
game of thrones like they were just
talking like modern people talk like
tyrion's just saying ah because i have
balls you're so silly varys you know
like he's just talking like people talk
now
i mean that's how i talk anyway um so i
think they're sort of returning to a bit
more of a medieval you know
shakespearean fancy old-timey way of
talking which i kind of enjoy
um thanks for the super chat from
gabriella who says it feels kind of
weird that damon killed a hightower
asked allison for a favor and then no
consequences came of it i don't think
that daemon killed a hightower um in the
tournament yeah they like daemon defeats
a high tower and and i like how i like
that he did that
um
like
damon chose to joust against gwen
hightower who is the son of otto
hightower because he dislikes otto
hightower because they are political
rivals so you know this wasn't just a
bunch of dudes hitting each other with
sticks there was all these sort of you
know grudges and politics that was
inherent in who was fighting her um i
mean it's like this baratheon guy chose
to get the favor of rhaenys targaryen
who is herself half baratheon her mother
was jocelyn baratheon
and the baratheon names her
the queen that never was which is a nod
to what happened back here in the
council at harrenhal when rhaenys was
skipped over um in favor of viserys so
like it wasn't just senseless tournament
stuff it was reminding us of the
relationships and the tensions that
underlie this whole situation i really
enjoyed the characterization of corliss
velaryon as well um because i like that
in this small council meeting back here
um
uh the other counselors are talking
about oh i've got to get this tournament
happening and like viserys is like
joking and just eating and having a good
time whereas corley's is trying to say
hey by the way there's a whole bunch of
pirates in the stepped stones they're
causing a ruckus like it could be a
threat to our wealth and our trade which
is especially relevant to the velaryons
because they uh you know got very rich
off trade because of their shipping
routes through the narrow sea
and callus is like hey like i think we
should do something about this uh but
everyone else is too busy talking about
like party festivities and tawnies and
stuff so you get the sense that corliss
is a guy who wants to focus on getting
[ __ ] done um he's not joking and eating
like the rest of them and he also
declines wine like yeah this moment here
alakaz just sort of says no to the wine
which is just a really simple way of
characterizing him as someone who
focuses on the task at hand because of
course is like a famous adventurer he
made his family the richest family in
westeros because of his explorations
because of his ambitions he's someone
who focuses on getting [ __ ] done not on
drinking and tournaments
thanks for the super chat from brett and
from randy and from night king
uh yeah the slaughter at the tourney
yeah i agree that was kind of weird um
[Music]
people are asking how long does the show
cover i mean i won't spoil the overall
timeline but um
there's a fairly long span of time
that's being covered and they've said
that the show will probably run for like
three or four seasons is their plan so
house of the dragon won't be as long um
as game of thrones was
um
and yeah thanks for the super chat from
jeffrey who says i'm so happy with how
this turned out thanks for the super
chat from syed who said will we get the
full history of the dagger as it was
supposed to be handed down to every heir
was a targaryen supposed to kill the
night king yeah okay let's talk about
the prophecy
let's talk about the prophecy so
this is a change from the books or it's
an addition to the books anyway um
so aegon the conqueror we talked about
aegon 300 years before game of thrones
and like a hundred and
[Music]
ten years before where we are now in
house of the dragon this guy aegon the
conqueror took over westeros and like
what the books say is that we don't know
exactly why he conquered westeros but
it's about ambition you know it's just
what he wanted to do you know men have
ambitions to power and conquest that's
that's kind of the assumed reason why
aegon conquered westeros but george
martin in interviews years ago has
brought up this idea of maybe
aegon had a prophetic dream or some
prophetic knowledge that the white
walkers the others would attack sometime
in the future the long night the
apocalyptic event that threatens all the
world
um which is
is something that has happened before 8
000 years ago in the first long night
and
now that's what viserys in the show says
to rhaenyra he says that the part of the
reason why aegon conquered westeros is
that he had this prophetic awareness
that the white walkers are going to come
one day and that there needs to be a
strong targaryen on the throne uniting
westeros in order to save humanity from
the white walkers and so i think you
know that they talked about it in the
inside the episode they're trying to
sort of add some stakes to this conflict
they're trying to connect this show to
the original game of thrones show
personally i don't love this change
because it reminds it reminds us of the
long night in season 8 episode 3 which
was you know very disappointing to a lot
of people like the long night was meant
to be a
a year of darkness and apocalyptic
hordes taking over everything and this
ongoing battle and a hero and a
sacrifice and a flaming sword but the
game of thrones tv show reduced it to
just like one night and then arya stark
came in with that valyrian steel dagger
and killed the night king then it was
all over um a lot of people were
disappointed by that and it looks like
it's going to be very very different in
the books because of course the books
that game of thrones was based on isn't
finished george r martin hasn't finished
the series which is you know a bit of a
bloody problem um
my point being that you know like
this prophecy that viserys is talking
about
it doesn't come true exactly does it
because he's saying that a targaryen
will be the one to save the world from
the long night but in game of thrones
season 8 it's not a targaryen it's arya
stark you know so
you know and he says that there must be
a targaryen on the throne but in game of
thrones season 8 there wasn't a
targaryen on the on the throne cersei
lannister was on the iron throne when
the white walkers were defeated so you
know
i mean it sort of fits in the sense that
prophecies in the books especially are
something that usually come true but not
in the way that you expect
um and you know that's true of viserys's
other dream in this show which is also
an addition to the story uh where
viserys talks about how he has a dream
that there's gonna be uh
he's gonna have a son and that son is
gonna be on the throne but you know that
turns out to be wrong when viserys's
baby son dies
so you know and of course in the books
there's lots and lots of examples of
targaryens having prophetic dreams that
often turn out to be
they come true in an unexpected way they
often lead to the downfall of the person
and i think that dreams
are a metaphor for ambition and desire
um and how our ambitions and our desires
can be our undoing which is certainly a
theme of this story
so so both of those dreams and
prophecies are not in the book they are
additions to the story in the show i
personally i like the one about
viserys believing he's gonna have a male
son an air i think that fits
uh however personally i don't love the
aegon thing like i kind of prefer for
aegon the conqueror to be
a conqueror like i think it is
reasonable that aegon would have some
awareness of the white walker prophecy
stuff because in the books there is all
of this stuff about you know there are
multiple targaryens in the books who are
aware of this prophecy about the prince
that was promised like maester aemon
targaryen is aware of this and like um
rhaegar becomes aware of this rhaegar
finds in his scrolls these writings
about the prince that was promised and
that inspires him to do what he does in
an attempt to save the world
which was its own disaster we've got a
video about rhaegar we've got a video
about a bunch of this stuff
um but the point is that you know
targaryens have always been aware of
this prophecy stuff so i don't mind if
like some of the targaryens are vaguely
aware of it but i really hope that it's
not like aegon was a great guy who was
just trying to save everyone and like
all those people who he burned it was
worth it because it was for the greater
good like i don't like that i don't like
making him some kind of hero i don't
like justifying his conquest because
aegon's conquest was very bloody and
very ugly you know
so yeah i don't know i hope we'll learn
more about all this prophecy business as
we go on
and yeah the whole like valyrian steel
dagger the special dagger the targaryens
have had for hundreds of years like we
see viserys wearing this dagger but in
the books there is like that dagger is
not like a super special dagger like it
doesn't have this history in the books
uh thanks for the super chat from brett
who says what are your thoughts in the
music yeah i enjoyed the music
specifically in this like rain era um
air naming ceremony i thought the music
was really cool there they definitely
leaned a lot on the game of thrones
uh soundtrack themes from the original
show like they were reusing a lot of
those familiar themes i i think like
they're really trying to
connect this to the original show when
personally i would kind of like it if
they did something a bit more different
if they distanced themselves from the
original show more because a lot of
people didn't like the original show
like my suspicion if i had to guess is
that i think this show probably will be
popular for like the hardcore fans and
people who have read the books and
people who are like really keen for more
thrones
uh and i'm sure there are lots of those
people but i suspect that like the more
casual fans and the more mainstream fans
uh viewers are maybe not gonna follow
this show as closely because like i
think for people who are not into the
law this show might be confusing it
might be slow it might remind them too
much of season eight you know uh because
like there are a lot of characters with
similar names and it's kind of hard to
keep track of who's related to who like
you need this bloody family tree to know
what's going on
so i i would not be shocked if the show
was not wildly popular with some of
those people
thanks for the donation from sam riley
who says was otto trying to pimp out his
daughter yeah let's talk about that so
otto hightower is the hand of the king
he's an ambitious scheming sort of a
bloke very powerful very influential uh
and he he's very reminiscent of tywin
lannister i think who is also hand of
the king in game of thrones he's got
very strong tywin vibes and otto after
the death of saris's wife emma uh otto
suggests to alison ah why don't you go
and comfort the king in his chambers
yeah go and do that and yeah i think
you're right to suspect that otto might
have ulterior motives there uh and then
alison goes and visits uh viserys and i
really love that viserys is playing with
like this model of valyria i suppose
like this architecture looks quite
similar to dragonstone which was also
built by the valyrians um
i i really like generally like the
emphasis on valyria in this show because
valyria is the old empire that the
targaryens originally came from
um and in this show like that
chronologically that was more recent in
this show you know um
valeria the memory of valyria is still
fresh so like in this conversation
between daemon and rhaenyra they're
talking in valyrian um and daemon gives
rainier a valyrian steel necklace uh the
steel that was made in valyria so i like
how the targaryens are more sort of
conscious of their valyrian heritage and
their valyrian history in this show and
that includes viserys building a cute
little model of valyria
uh i quite enjoy that it's cute it's
like a guy playing with like a model
train set or something uh there's a lot
of stuff you know in the interviews and
the inside the episode about you know
like
viserys never really should have been
king like he's just not he hasn't got
the right personality to be king he's
not good at making hard choices
i mean he says to his counsel
um at one point that you know i will not
be made to choose between my brother
damon and my daughter
rhaenyra like i don't want to choose who
my heir is but like like viserys mate
like you're the king you have to choose
the whole point of a king is to make the
tough decisions and viserys is really
bad at doing that he wants everyone to
get along he doesn't want to piss anyone
off he just wants harmony but like a
king needs to make hard choices and
that's viserys's problem
thanks for the super chat from nora who
says your channel is one of the best
things on youtube i love it and your
voice so much your one-offs like all
tomorrow is a top shelf and i'm happy to
see new videos thank you so much nora
thanks for the super chat from james who
says i think we can safely assume
nymeria and ten thousand ships is being
seriously backed by hbo
yeah so we had a conversation between
rhaenyra and allison in the godswood um
so i like i like their friendship it's
very reminiscent of
sansa stark and istark in game of
thrones and the books in that sansa is
very ruler-biding and she's a proper
noble lady whereas rhaenyra is more uh
rebellious she's described as punk rock
in one of the uh interviews and you know
unlike arya and sansa who
are rivals and are mean to each other
and are not friends
uh in the show alison and rhaenyra are
friends despite their differences which
which i enjoy as a contrast and this
relationship is invented for the show
like in the books uh rainier and allison
to different ages
they don't have this they didn't grow up
together like this but i enjoy this
addition to the show um and yeah they're
reading this book about nymeria and the
ten thousand ships so nymeria was a
princess of the roina many years ago and
she was part of this ethnic group in the
east who were attacked by the valyrians
and so they escaped from essos they
escaped from the valyrians they voyaged
across the world trying to find a new
world a new land for their people a new
homeland and they eventually came to
dorne and princess nymeria the leader
married a dornishman called maus martell
and they
became part of the dornish people um and
the the the rhoynar people joining the
dornish is part of why the dornish are
different like ethically and legally and
culturally to the rest of westeros and
one of those differences is that in dawn
women can inherit just as much as men
can men and women are equal in
inheritance in dawn unlike in the rest
of westeros where men come first uh so
nymeria is is a really interesting story
and there are reports that hbo is
working on a tv show about nymeria and
her voyage which i think could be pretty
cool there's a lot of like adventures
and wild stuff that happens in that
story like nymeria and heroina go to
sothoryos which is like the sort of
mysterious jungle continent in the south
and all sorts of there's like spooky
lovecraftian stone and disappearances
and all sorts of crap that goes on that
i think would make for an interesting if
expensive tv show so yeah i think you
might be right uh james that the mention
of nymeria under ships in this
episode may be an indication that hbo is
taking that spin-off show seriously
uh
thanks for the superchat from monco who
yeah otto again thanks for to derrick
who enjoyed daemon and rainier speaking
valyrian thanks for the super chat from
the american dream who says it's weird
to me that rhaenyra said dracarus at
emma's funeral to burn the pyre i
thought that was just what daenerys
taught her dragons in a song of ice and
fire no that that is valyrian um the
valyrian language is is what the
valyrians had used for a long time to
command their dragons uh presumably and
yeah daenerys did not invent valyrian um
there is a whole legit valyrian language
that was developed by um what's his name
someone peterson who like created the
languages
for this show and created dothraki as
well he created not george r martin
because george armadan the author he's
not a linguist he's not tolkien he
doesn't invent whole languages like
tolkien did um but he did make some
words like dracaris in the books and
then peterson created the whole
languages based on that and i believe
you can learn these languages on
duolinguo um
i'm not sure why you'd want to honestly
but you can
thanks for the super chat from sweetness
who says doesn't a grand targaryen white
walker dream remove the mystery of
rhaegar deciding to become a warrior and
azor ahai
so yeah as we were saying like there is
a history of targaryens being aware
of the prince that was promised prophecy
to save the world i i think it i mean i
think it fits that like it makes sense
that viserys may have been aware of this
stuff but like i mean i agree with you
that that telling us this in the first
episode of house of the dragon it kind
of yeah it does take away the mystery it
demystifies the whole prophecy thing
because in the books it's still very
unclear like who knows what like it's
not really clear like is the prince that
was promised the same as azor ahai like
what exactly does the prophecy say like
melisandre says that stannis is azor
ahai and she's had her dreams and like
other people have other opinions and
like there's other cultures in the world
who have
other stories about a woman with a
monkey's tail and there's like the
bloodstone emperor who is suspiciously
like azor ahai the point being that the
story is very sort of mysterious and
complicated in the books and having the
first episode of house of the dragons
say oh yeah there's frosty boys coming
so we targaryens better be ready for
those frosty white walkers we gotta be
in charge it's like oh okay you know and
showing us the dagger that arya will use
i i do find it a little bit unsatisfying
like i can see why they did it because
they want to connect it to the show and
raise the stakes to an apocalyptic level
but i kind of like it when the stakes
are more human and the stakes are just
these are ambitious people who want
power you know so
i i don't love that addition to the
story thanks for the super chat from
actual goblin who says that the dialogue
had the characters explaining their
feelings to the audience too much
i mean pilots are hard especially for a
story this complicated like like you
know when they made the original game of
thrones pilot uh
it was a disaster partly because viewers
couldn't tell what the relationships of
all the characters were like there were
people who didn't realize that jaime
lannister and cersei lannister were
siblings um so i think that they're
trying to make it really clear who the
people are and what their feelings are
and what their relationships are because
most people aren't paying that much
attention most casual viewers
don't know
all the details of what's going on so
like i think it makes sense that they're
trying to make it clear um especially
for the pilot episode and maybe they can
be a little bit more subtle as it goes
along thanks for the super chat from
evan who says that cersei lannister
confirmed secret targaryen there are a
lot of secret targaryen theories in the
books for sure thanks for the super chat
from kb who says is this show canon to
the song of ice and fire books or the
game of thrones show yeah i mean i
i think it's closer to the game of
thrones show than it is to the books i
mean there are differences between this
show and the books and it is connecting
itself to the game of thrones show law
like with that special dagger and the
prophecy and stuff um so i i think that
we can consider this
more canon to the show than to the books
but i mean i will note that
the the co-creator and kosher
co-showrunner of this show ryan condell
said that their goal with this show is
to create a objective account of this
conflict the dance of the dragons um in
the book it's presented as a history
book where there's lots of different
versions and opinions on what really
happened during this conflict there's
this guy mushroom and eustace who say oh
that thing happened with alison and that
other guy says no that thing happened
with alison whereas this show is going
to present well this is what really
happened and you know george r martin
the author is involved in this show like
a lot of the changes and a lot of the
things that are added to this show you
know approved by him um so you know like
it is connected to book law but it's its
own thing it's not the same as the books
thanks to the super chat from musa who
says is it possible that the show is
going to forego the game of thrones show
canon in favor of doing its own thing
that's more aligned to the books yeah
well as i just said like
they are doing things that are more
connected to the game of thrones show
lore like the valyrian steel dagger and
also the velaryons being black is like a
change from the books that probably
impacts the law in certain ways so i
think it is part of the show canon as
opposed to the books canon
uh thanks for the super chat from urden
who says it seems like the dream of the
white walker prophecy was passed on with
spoken word that could lead to
alterations like the telephone game or
like yeah chinese whispers is another
term yeah i i agree like these
prophecies uh and these histories and
these like information about the white
walkers
in the books it's been passed down and
passed down over thousands of years and
so yes like that absolutely is something
in the books that these prophecies have
been misinterpreted and altered and lost
and fragmentary and so no no one really
knows what happened in the last long
night the last time the white walk was
attacked a lot of people don't believe
white walkers ever existed we don't even
know how long ago it happened like some
people are like oh the white walkers
were 8 000 years ago or like others say
10 000 years ago
there were some fans who even questioned
the timeline in terms of like when the
long night happened in relation to when
the andals came which was like an ethnic
group that came from the east and like
you know was the night's king
at the time of the long night or was it
afterwards because it was the 13th lord
commander like gamer like george martin
really plays with the idea of history
and bias and information being lost and
forgotten so that so yeah and
misinterpretations of prophecy are a big
part of it
thanks for the super chat from
sam thanks for the super chat from
andrew um
thanks for the super chat from sean
uh we already talked about rhaenyra and
allison thanks for the super chat from
joseph who says that the last season of
got we've seen may not actually be the
last season what we saw was a false
winter can we dream i remember when game
of thrones season 8 episode 3 the long
night came out i i wanted to believe
that that wasn't the end of the white
walker plotline because it just seemed
so anticlimactic compared to you know
the the build-up that was in the show
and all the information that's in the
books but um
yeah i don't think we're getting a game
of thrones season nine guys although
there is talk of a game of thrones uh
there is talk of a jon snow
show
being made george martin and kit
harrington have talked about it um and i
i don't see how that would work i don't
see that being a good idea personally
but george martin seems to think a jon
snow spin-off is a good idea so
hell i don't know is it going to just be
him hanging out beyond the wall and you
know being buddies with tormund and
falling in love with another wildling
redhead i don't know what it would be i
i guess i'm intrigued thanks for the
super chat from mukka and from basically
a god who says what do we think about
all the new armor and costumes yeah i
really enjoy the armor i mean something
that i've noticed in like the trailers
even like we see callers valarion
wearing a helmet um and we see daemon
wearing a helmet in this tourney and
like helmets were avoided by the game of
thrones tv show mostly
i guess because it makes it harder to
see the characters faces but i like you
know it's a certain commitment to
realism because you know the game of
thrones attempts to show like the real
ugly side of violence like people get
maimed and injured and people get
traumatized like game of thrones is a
very violent story but it tries to show
the cost of violence honestly
and i think you know part of that sense
of weight and realism is is having
things like helmets and cool armor and
the splendor of all the armor as well as
the ugliness of the violence at the same
time like that's sort of an interesting
tension that's at the start at the heart
of the story is that you know georgia
armadan is a romantic who loves the
knights and the heraldry and the fantasy
and the magic and the beauty of it all
but at the same time he is so conscious
of the darkness and the injustice and
the horror
and and the consequences of ambition and
the politics and and you know so so
that's this fundamental tension where
george loves the fantasy but also is so
deeply
disillusioned and skeptical and cynical
of the fantasy at the same time
thanks for the super chat uh
from cat who says anyone reminded of
queen eliza's death with emma's yeah
let's talk about that so
in this episode uh king viserys's wife
uh emma
aaron uh gave birth to
balon a little baby who died immediately
after being born uh let me just find
where that bit was well yeah here's the
funeral pyre
uh with emma aaron and the baby balon on
the pyre so
during the birthing scene uh emma aaron
was having a complicated pregnancy and
it looked like she was gonna die and the
maester told viserys that we can't save
emma but we might be able to save the
baby balon and so viserys agreed to have
the baby cut out of emma's belly which
was the only way to potentially save the
baby but they ended up both dying now
that is a change from the books in the
books emma aaron dies in childbirth but
there's no mention of cutting her belly
open
um it was such a such a horrifying scene
watching emma cut open and die like that
in the interviews the showrunners have
said that game of thrones uh house of
the dragon will do for childbirth what
game of thrones did for weddings because
of course there was the memorable and
bloody red wedding in game of thrones uh
and in-house the dragon and in the book
fire and blood childbirth and the
violence and the danger and the
injustice of childbirth is a theme
throughout the book
and so uh what cat is bringing up in the
super chat is that there is this
character alyssa velaryon who is jahiris
targaryen's mother in the books uh this
woman here alyssa
um who gets married to a baratheon bloke
later on and she keeps getting pregnant
into her 40s
um and the maces are saying that like
hey it's it's really dangerous for you
to be getting pregnant again when when
you're like 40 years old but her husband
the baratheon roger baratheon was like
nah it's cool mate she can keep getting
pregnant it's fine uh but then she had
these complicated pregnancies and then
she had a baby cut out of her just like
with emma aaron um and the baby
incidentally was jocelyn baratheon who
is rhaenys targaryen's mother so the
baby survived in
in that case but yeah this whole choice
of like will you cut open the woman to
try and save the baby that that's taken
from alyssa's story in the book and in
the book like they they frame it as you
know they ask her husband the baratheon
like
do you want to try and save the wife or
do you want to try and save the baby
and
the husband the baratheon says
save the baby save my son
and so there's this sense that like
women are being sacrificed women are
being killed
for the sake of producing male heirs for
this power system and you get the sense
that you know like like in this case
viserys i mean i mean they kind of let
viserys off the hook in in this case in
house of the dragon because they made it
clear that viserys
that there was no way to save his wife
emma in this case they could only
attempt to save the baby by cutting her
open it's still bloody horrifying the
way emma was like like saying no please
i'm scared while she was being killed by
the maesters on viserys's word
um but like with alyssa in the books
like
it's really emphasized that they kind of
killed her by making her have babies
like that's true even of uh king
jiharis's wife alisain targaryen like
king jaehaerys fathered like bloody 10
kids on alisaine even as she was getting
older and alisane told jiharis in the
books and said like hey
i can't have any more children for you
like this could kill me quote you must
be content with the children i have
given you but johary's her husband
insisted on know i'm gonna have more
children with you and he kept on
impregnating her um and it was really
dangerous to her health and then like
one of their children daela uh died in
childbirth and alisaine said that hey
our daughter is dead because we married
her off too young like we made her bare
children too young so like throughout
fire and blood there's this really
strong sense that you know using women
to produce babies when it's so dangerous
for them
when it's done when they're too young or
too old or just not healthy enough
it's it's this horrific violence that is
inflicted on women and you know that's
partly the fault of the men who keep
impregnating them even when it's
dangerous to their wives and it's also
the fault of this whole monarchical
system where the stability of this
political world relies on the production
of male heirs you need to have lots of
babies to inherit your throne because if
you don't have a clear air you're gonna
have a conflict
um so it's the system that's wrong and
it's the men who are wrong and it's the
children who are wrong
um there's a lot that's [ __ ] up and
and this story in house of the dragon is
partly about this it's partly about how
this power structure how this patriarchy
is dangerous and unfair and i think it's
really cool how they sort of emphasized
that in this episode of house of the
dragon
and they really showed how rhaenyra
views this because they make it really
clear in the show that rhaenyra has seen
that her
mother died because of this imperative
to produce children i mean like emma in
this episode was saying to viserys like
hey this is the last child i'm giving
birth to you i've had multiple
miscarriages i've had multiple
stillborns i can't keep producing babies
for you so like this is another example
of the woman being pushed and pushed to
make babies beyond uh her safety um and
and rhaenyra in this episode is so
painfully aware of that that this system
and her father killed her mother
basically and so that frames rhaenyra's
story around this issue of like gender
and power in westeros and of course
that's very relevant to when rhaenyra
becomes declared heir and you know some
people are not happy about rainer being
air because she's a woman so yeah those
are some of the themes of the story
um
thanks for the super chat from
christopher who says do you think we
will see
uh so that so you're referring to
something that's a bit of a spoiler i'm
going to avoid spoilers in this live
stream maybe we'll have like a spoiler
corner at the very end but i'm going to
avoid spoilers um
but uh to answer your question anyway
christopher there is stuff in the
trailer that
uh confirms your question uh thanks for
the super chat from otto who says uh
yeah yes so like you know otto told
allison to go and comfort viserys and
that
mirrors something that is in the books
so in the books
uh otto was made hand of the king and in
the time of king jaehaerys and so otto
brought allison to court with him and in
the book uh alison had a relationship
with jiharis where she sort of nursed
him and read to him in his last years as
he was
you know heading towards death
and um in the book the dwarf jester
mushroom who is one of the sort of
historical sources in the book fire and
blood claims that alice and performed
sexual favors for jiharis in the book
and we don't know whether that's true
um but yeah like the sort of uh alice
and
uh viserys relationship in the show does
sort of evoke that um
jiharis stuff in the books thanks for
the super chat from benjamin who says
why isn't viserys remarrying and having
a son uh why is that not a possibility
uh well that's an interesting
possibility that may be discussed later
on thanks to the super chat from manuel
thanks for the super chat from meta
texture who says my dad thought this
would be about young dany and he's
confused about why her parents are alive
and where is her crazy brother and what
happened to the dwarf he really wanted
to see a young tyrion yeah well this is
not about um the characters who are in
game of thrones it's about new
characters a long long time back which
you know they had like a text thing 172
years before the birth of daenerys
targaryen
it is conceivable that they could do a
show about robert's rebellion which is
about when robert baratheon defeated the
mad king aerys targaryen and daenerys
was born
um you know they could do that and show
us some of the characters we know and
love um but yeah this is about different
characters thanks for the super chat
from captain guts who says i really
liked the kingsguard who was watching
the princess in the beginning will we
see more of him so yeah we have this
character harold westerling who is the
lord commander of the king's guard uh
and we don't really know much about him
he's just like a honorable noble guy who
likes to follow the rules like i like
how when uh
he walked rainier into the throne room
and he's and harold saw damon on the
throne and he was like god's be good
because you know damon should not be
sitting on the throne
um
so you know harold seems to be a sort of
a proper guy i also liked being
introduced to the dragon keepers um so
in the books they mentioned that there
are these dragon keepers who are the
people who like guard the dragon pit and
they wear this fancy armor whereas in
this case they seem
like they're described in interviews as
like an order of monks almost
um and i like how they had this guy who
was clearly like a novice dragon keeper
who was being taught by this dragon
keeper uh they sort of told this whole
sort of mini story about these two
people and just with that you know
barely any dialogue um
i'm curious to see what else they
introduced because some of the sort of
dragon law dragon culture dragon
infrastructure is mentioned in the books
but we're certainly learning more about
it in house of the dragon and i imagine
a lot of this is based on george's ideas
uh thanks to the superchat from syed who
says can house of the dragon go back in
time to aegon's conquest then jump
forward to the future like the blackfyre
rebellion yes so the showrunners in
interviews have said that like the plan
is that you know these first three or
four seasons are going to cover this
particular story about these characters
in this time period but if it's as if
it's a success they might cover other
periods in targaryen history because the
book fire and blood tells
170 years of history about king aegon
and king aenes and king maegor and and
after and also all over the place so
there's there's a lot of years of
history that they could cover so maybe
house of the dragon uh will cover other
time periods as well i think that could
be cool
uh thanks to this for the super chat
from jim philbert who says pull one out
for lane or velaryon so yeah so in this
great council in 101 there were multiple
options considered as to who should be
the next ruler and you know yeah in the
books like they're not just considering
viserys and rhaenys as the potential
rulers even more than rhaenys
they consider rhaenys's son lenore
velaryon
who is
this bloke
here and in the books lenore is
one of the popular contenders partly
because he's the son of callus velaryon
and the valarions are very rich and very
powerful and very influential so they
really push trying to get laner on the
throne um but ultimately viserys is
chosen instead um so
yeah i i imagine we're gonna get to lane
on later but this the whole sort of
velaryon story of rainey s and corliss's
ambitions and their hopes is is um you
know it's going to be relevant
thanks for the super chat from kaiser
who says do you think by the end of the
story knowing how the war gets resolved
the prophecy might be lost and not
passed on yeah i mean maybe that's what
they might do with this whole aegon's
prophecy thing like maybe viserys's
viserys telling rhaenyra like hey we've
got to pass on this information about
we've got to stop the white walkers uh
maybe that will be forgotten and then
maybe that's why uh rhaegar rediscovered
the prophecy years later generations
later and maybe that'll add some tragedy
to the conflict to come maybe i don't
know um i think that
i think that's plausible but i mean like
why is this prophecy a secret anyway
like why are the targaryens not shouting
from the rooftops hey there is a threat
that may come from the north at some
point so let's be prepared for it let's
hand out dragonglass daggers let's you
know tell the common people let's create
like an almost religious fervor around
this apocalyptic vision like why why is
it secret you know why are we not uh
reinforcing the night's watch and like
telling them telling the night's watch
yo like we are aware of white walkers or
we gotta do something about it like does
that does that make sense i don't know
why is it gonna be a secret you know and
there's gotta be something sort of
self-serving in that like the way that
viserys tells this prophecy is by saying
that you know and that's why the
targaryens have to be in charge because
of the white walkers whereas other
interpretations of the prophecy do not
say like and that's why a targaryen has
to be on the throne like when melisandre
says hey like we need to stop the white
walkers she says and that's why stannis
baratheon needs to be on the throne
so just like in real life and in real
history
prophecy and mysticism and religion is
used to justify whatever political
whatever politician you like you know
like kings all throughout history have
had mandates from heaven and like
mystical religious reasons like the king
was chosen by god chosen by the church
to rule and so i i guess in that sense i
like the targaryens using prophecy as a
justification for their political
ambitions
um maybe it's not quite as selfless as
it seems maybe it's more politically
self-serving um i could see that being a
thing you know like everyone centers
themselves in their own prophecies i
mean it's like how you know
a lot of religious people could be said
to have you know you believe that you
were born into the people whose religion
is the right religion you know like the
religion of your parents just happens to
be the right religion not any of those
other religions that other people were
born into but anyway whatever
it it'll be interesting to see how this
prophecy stuff develops thanks for the
super chat from mikey who says i love
your channel fellow book fan been
reading since middle school what do you
think are our chances of seeing mushroom
or eustace
so yeah in the book fire and blood we
have these different historical sources
mushroom and eustace and monken
here's
his mushroom
art by
rossi does drawings
and mushroom
has all these salacious tales about what
went down mushroom was a jester to
viserys targaryen in the books there he
is viserys patty considine in fire and
blood um and so since mushroom was there
it yeah we may plausibly see mushroom i
feel like maybe mushroom
is just too
silly to be like this this show has a
fairly serious tone i don't know if
they're going to introduce mushroom and
like frankly a lot of mushrooms
contributions to the story are just kind
of cringe like my all mushroom does is
says oh that person secretly had sex
with that person or that person secretly
murdered that person and threw him out a
window and there's all sorts of
salacious
rumors that mushroom spreads that might
not be what they're going for in this tv
adaptation i mean maybe they could put
mushroom in just as like an easter egg
like maybe mushroom will just be in the
background at a feast or a banquet or
something like that would make sense and
that would be like a cool nod for the
book readers but i'm not expecting
mushroom to turn up and have a bunch of
dialogue in this show nor eustace um
especially since they're not really
doing the
historical ambiguity multiple sources
thing they're doing an objective story
so you know
thanks for the super chat from austin
and from sanguini who says i love the
parallels between promise me ned and
promise me rhaenyra do you think that
aegon's dream could be the same to
bran's crow dream when he looks north
and sees the others
yeah that's a good point so viserys in
in this episode says terrania promise me
that you're going to
deal with these white walkers or promise
me that you'll remember and pass on this
prophecy which yeah it's similar to
lyanna stark saying to ned stuck promise
me ned promise me you're gonna look
after jon snow who in the books uh
incidentally is looking like john will
be involved in fighting the white
walkers in the books unlike in the show
so yeah there is a parallel there and uh
you point out that bran stark also uh
sees the cold heart of winter bran sees
the threat beyond the wall in the books
in the books every second main character
has prophetic dreams and visions and a
lot of people are aware of that that
danger in in some sense or another um
and yeah like you can also
question whether these dreams and
prophecies are
potentially manipulations by outside
forces like in the books daenerys has
visions of quaithe who is that masked
lady in carth in the books and in the
show
um
quaithe is able to enter people's dreams
possibly using a glass candle in the
books this is art by lauren k cannon
uh and quite appeared in the in the show
also in season two
um
so you know people are able to send
dreams like purposefully and some people
wonder if maybe dreams might not just be
seeing the truth dreams might be you're
being manipulated by people some people
suspect that the children of the forest
and bloodraven use dreams to manipulate
people um so there's all sorts of
there's like a sinister manipulative
aspect to the dreams potentially
some people suggest that the children of
the forest might have sent all these
dreams um there's all sorts of theories
so you know i i don't i i wouldn't
imagine that they're gonna go deep into
the dreams and prophecies in this story
but i don't know we will see what
happens thanks for the super chat from
captains and paper who says if the
prophecy was passed down it might help
explain why bloodraven does what he does
if he's working off the idea that that
is the targaryen's destiny yeah well
there are definitely multiple targaryens
who have been aware
of this prophecy or similar prophecies
and bloodraven is one of them
thanks for the super chat from maylie
who says it broke my heart the look on
king viserys's eyes after he sent daemon
away and saw him leaving yeah i thought
that was a nice scene like it sort of
makes it clear that viserys viserys and
damon they do love each other but
they've just never been able to get
along properly or to communicate
properly like viserys sees damon as a
nuisance and damon certainly makes
himself a nuisance uh but
daemon just sort of wants
acknowledgement and love from his
brother and he's just sort of acting out
to get attention uh but in this
particular case like viserys is so raw
and he's in grief from the death of his
wife and child and he sort of
directs all those emotions and all that
grief and he turns it into rage against
daemon um so yeah there's definitely a
sadness in like seeing this relationship
break down when it could have been such
a positive relationship i mean like uh
viserys and daemon's own father baylon
was very close with his brother aemon
you know so it's a tragedy that this
brotherly relationship uh is is not as
close and not as successful
thanks for the super chat from spirit
can you say who says can you explain why
daemon went and mutilated all those
peasants i don't really understand yeah
that was pretty over the top wasn't it
um so we saw damon and his gold cloaks
the city watch of king's landing
go and do this brutally violent
crackdown on alleged criminals in king's
landing supposedly like what damon says
they're doing is they're going and
punishing a bunch of criminals murderers
and rapists and thieves uh and so he
personally does a lot of the executions
and killings and and that is in the book
as well it says that daemon delights in
mutilating and cutting up peasants uh so
you know damon's a bad guy
damon enjoys violence and and killing
and he's he's a he is kind of monstrous
um and yeah supposedly all the people
they were killing were criminals but
like were they really like was there
evidence was there due process you know
doesn't look like these people got a
trial did it
so yeah i don't think it seems like a
very fair thing and i think what this is
more about is about damon exerting power
winning loyalty instilling fear
daemon wants power
thanks for the super chat from my debt
my dad after a bath who says dunk an egg
show on the table do you think my dude
yeah there has been reporting that there
may be a game of thrones spin-off show
about dunk and egg dunk and egg are a
couple of characters who exist years
after house of the dragon and years
before game of thrones and there a
charming couple of characters who go on
adventures the whole story of dunkin egg
is much more small scale than
house of the dragon and fire and blood
or game of thrones it's mostly just a
couple of couple of dudes just just
hanging out traveling meeting some
characters occasionally getting in a
fight trying to do justice trying to do
the right thing
uh you get to see a baby world of fray
that's fun
um
so i think that a duncan egg show could
potentially be really cool um but one of
the issues with that idea is that the
duncan egg series is not finished george
martin has not finished most of his
projects um
unfortunately so i think if they try to
make a dunkin egg show they're just
gonna have the same problem that they
had with game of thrones they're gonna
run out of books because there's been
three duncan egg novellas published when
george says that he wants to tell their
full story which will probably take
eight or ten or twelve novellas
so they've only got like thirty percent
of the story it would be silly to start
a tv adaptation when the books aren't
finished so i would love to see a dunkin
egg story after george has finished the
books but doing it before then seems
foolish thanks to the super chat from
surfing and saint who says shout out to
the glimpse of sausage dog karaxis best
boy
yeah so we got to see a lot of dragons
in this episode um karaxis is daemon's
dragon he's called the blood worm and he
is very long for some reason
we can see that uh karaxis has a very
long neck and he also has wings on his
hind legs which apparently they added
according to interviews because they
realize that when
kharaxis is super long he just is not
aerodynamic i mean i don't know if
dragons were ever meant to be
scientifically aerodynamic but because
he's so ridiculously long they decided
to add extra wings to the back
in the books uh the dragons are all like
different colors um
but house of the dragon is going even
further in making them all unique and
distinguishable because there's like at
least a dozen of them who are important
to the story so uh yeah we're gonna see
a lot more dragon stuff thanks for the
super chat from epic mark who says
thoughts on coal beating damon by skill
and a trixie weapon being replaced with
a cheap shot to the back makes him seem
dishonorable right away
um
i don't know what you mean i don't know
if i saw it that way i thought kristen
cole beat damon pretty legit
um but maybe
i can rethink that thanks for the super
chat from night king who says i thought
the city watch didn't get their gold
clerks a name from damon no he did uh
and also knight points out that the
hightower night gwain had a chess piece
for a helmet yeah i mean something that
the game of thrones uh books do is have
a lot of
silly armor like there's a guy in the
game of thrones books who has a like a
narwhal tusk because he's like a unicorn
guy and like tywin lannister has no less
than three lions on top of his armor
made out of gold with ruby eyes like the
the drip is over the top in the books
like these knights and lords are really
trying to show off their house colors
their wealth um so they've all got crazy
armor and i i do like that they're doing
a little bit of that um in this show and
yeah that's what you mean the little
crenellations on his helmet because
house hightower has a very
high tower in old town and so that's
what that is symbolizing
thanks for the super chat from sav who
says we get so much of an idea of
viserys's personality after the maester
asked him to choose he didn't want to he
loved his wife dragon dreams destroy his
family i totally agree savannah i really
enjoyed the acting when they asked
viserys you know should we kill your
wife in an attempt to
uh save your baby son and i loved the
way that viserys sort of looked away he
looked to the side he looked up he
looked down he looked like he was trying
to escape from the conversation you know
he just did not want to make a decision
he felt trapped by his responsibility he
felt weighed down by his responsibility
he does love his wife he also feels a
duty to sire a son and to fulfill the
dreams and yeah i think that totally
fits in with this whole sense that the
dragon dreams are what destroy the
targaryens over and over and over
maester aemon said that dreams killed my
brothers everyone and these dreams are
so often about ambition and wanting to
be more and
it's that ambition that gets people
killed and i think that is um a theme of
the entire story for sure
um thanks
for the super chat from rachel and james
who says the jon snow sequel could be
about him leading the resistance against
a force like the skargosi or the
ibbenese yeah there's lots of sort of
things that can make up for the jon snow
sequel but it all just seems like a sort
of a weird
epilogue vestigial extra tact on story i
yeah i don't know um night king in the
super chat says they said no gratuitous
sex so we did see a bit of a orgy
situation with uh damon targaryen uh
buying out a brothel for his city watch
to win their loyalty and i thought it
was very funny the way damon was sitting
there in the middle of the orgy fully
clothed just drinking wine and being a
sad boy it reminded me of that meme of
like that guy standing in the corner at
a party thinking oh they don't even know
that i'm the prince of the city i have a
dragon called garaxies i don't know i
thought that his acting was kind of
funny and also in an earlier scene where
he was having sex with mizaria um i
thought it was interesting that like
damon it seemed as though damon he like
stopped having sex midway through as
though he like couldn't get satisfaction
he couldn't get off with missouri and
that is a nice metaphor for daemon's
personality he is unsatisfied he can't
get no satisfaction as the rolling
stones once said and that is sort of
what daemon's about like he has this
unfulfilled need um and he has this
energy that he needs to get out i mean
it's like rainey said at the tournament
scene scene she said something about
like
all these men have so much seed in their
bowls or something crude like that and
it's kind of true like there is this
pent-up energy in all of these men and
that pent-up energy is uh causing
destruction
thanks for the super chat from gustavo
and princess
um
who said that my mom had a c-section
with my brother in a developing nation
and it wasn't done properly emma's death
gave her bad flashbacks and she called
it murder yeah damn well yeah it does
feel like that i mean in this case when
they're cutting open emma aaron they
know that it's killing her uh and it's
messed up
thanks for the super chat from the old
gods who loves the dune video thanks for
the super chat from capt who says glad
you're live the dragon keepers were
interesting really enjoyed episode one
uh thanks for the super chat from rafael
who says my biggest problem with the
house of the dragon is that it will lead
to what people hated about game of
thrones yeah it's weird to link it to
season 8. um something else i'd like to
say about the tourney at harrenhal so i
mentioned that there were
a bunch of different people considered
to become king jiharis's heir
in the show here they mention princess
rhaenys who is the eldest child of king
joharis's eldest son um in the books
they also mention vagon targaryen who is
a
well wagon is the oldest living son of
king jiharis so he was kind of
considered but they didn't choose vagon
to be the new king because he was a nerd
who no one liked basically vegan
targaryen was a maester
and maesters swear not to
be the king and stuff like that and
fagon is just like a very dislikable guy
so he was sort of considered but he
didn't become king um another person
they talked to was sarah targaryen who
is a daughter of king jaehaerys
and sarah ran off and joined a brothel
and became a sort of a sex worker queen
in an eastern city and they asked sarah
like hey like do you hypothetically
maybe want to like come home and like be
queen maybe and she was like nah nah nah
nah i i have my own kingdom here
jihara's had a really uh
complicated and unpleasant relationship
with sarah and with several of his
children king jahirus is widely seen as
like a really good king who did a lot of
good stuff reformed laws built roads did
justice brought peace but he had bad and
complicated relationships with some of
the women in his life and you know
constantly fathering
uh children on his wife alisain in a way
that endangered her health is part of
that
um
and yeah this whole like succession
issue this whole crisis of who becomes
king after jaehaerys is arguably partly
his fault for having so many different
children and grandchildren who all have
these competing ambiguous claims
something else i was curious about is
that we didn't see an opening theme we
didn't see an opening intro sequence for
this show
um i thought that you know like game of
thrones
when it pans over the map and everything
there was no new opening sequence for
this show maybe we'll see it next
episode
um
i really enjoyed when they were
introducing the red keep uh when
rhaenyra and alison were coming in and
we saw all of this splendor we saw all
of these different people these lords
and ladies and courtiers in the red keep
which is something that was missing from
a lot of game of thrones i think like
there's a sense that the red keep is a
really vibrant place and that speaks to
the influence and the busyness and the
how many targaryens there are and how
many people there are i really enjoy the
splendid that they have here
and by the way the uh this particular
courtyard that they're standing in right
now is part of the
room in the game of thrones show where
cersei paints that map
here it is in um season seven
it looks like
the same
room over here
you can see these same arches and
columns so this is the same place
170 years earlier so i like how they i
like those little subtle ties like it's
the same place
same throne different game thanks for
the super chat from sean who says the
baratheons were cousins to aegon the
first they reasonably have dragon blood
in them playing by song of ice and fire
rules would be able to ward off the
white walkers
yeah i mean lots of people have
intermarried with the targaryens and
yeah the baratheons have more than most
um so maybe bloody gendry should have
killed the white walkers
thanks for the super chat from
christopher and from
nick
um
and from basically a god who says in
theory is melisandre alive right now ooh
that is an interesting question
um melisandre is very old we don't know
how old she was apparently a slave in
the east in asshai at one point her
original name was melanie in the game of
thrones tv show we saw that melisandre
has like this very old body that she's
like concealing with with magic or
something um so i yeah i guess plausibly
melisandre might be alive at this point
170 years before game of thrones um
maybe she'll turn up maybe she'll do a
cameo maybe we'll see kinvara i don't
know thanks for the super chat from
idlingham who says will alt shift be
making another westworld rant video
uh i don't know i i have no idea what
alt shift x might do i have not made
westworld season 4 videos um i would
like to watch westworld season 4 at some
point i heard that it's good um but yeah
not what i'm working on right now
libertas says will there be explained
videos for this show so yeah the plan is
that every week we'll do a live stream
like this immediately after each episode
of house of the dragon at 10 15 p.m
eastern time every sunday uh like and
subscribe press press the bell so you
get notified
and we will then make a explained video
which is going to summarize and analyze
each episode and i expect that'll be out
around
thursday or friday each week hopefully
it depends how much happens and how much
there is to discuss thanks for the super
chat from malcolm uh do you have a
desktop full of fan art for these
streams um yeah there's a
system
as a system uh thanks for the super chat
from kclv who says damon fighter of the
night man champion of the sun you're a
master of karate and friendship for
everyone
uh
yes
kryptonian says how did the newborn baby
die uh it doesn't say but you know
that's something that happens even in
the real world sometimes babies die it's
um one of the biggest things that's
changed with modern medicine like they
talk a lot about how um average life
expectancy has changed dramatically like
average lifespan is much longer now than
it used to be in the past and one of the
main reasons for that is that healthcare
and medicine and science has made babies
survive their first five years much more
often it used to be that babies died in
their early years much more often but
that doesn't happen as much anymore and
the game of thrones world is trying to
be sort of realistic to that
uh by showing the dangers of childbirth
thanks for the super chat from midtoker
who says matt smith was great is it just
me or was the cgi way worse than the
original show i thought some of the cgi
was a bit suspect in this show like
specifically when they burned
the emma and the baby on the pyre like
that cgi looks a bit [ __ ] doesn't it is
that just me
it doesn't look
good
to in my opinion um so yeah so yeah some
of the cgi wasn't great which i'm
surprised by like i thought they were
spending like an absurd amount of money
on this but um i thought overall it
looks good i thought like the production
design and the costumes and the sets and
the armor are all pretty good but yeah
some of the dragons in the cgi not so
much thanks for the super chat from
robbie
and from brinks thanks for the super
chat from seren who says the scene where
viserys had his hands on the flames an
ability that not every targaryen had
yeah so we did have viserys uh putting
his hand on some candles here which is
interesting because like something that
has always been a little ambiguous a
little bit different between the tv show
and the books uh is that targaryens in
the books are sort of resistant to heat
like daenerys takes really hot baths
and egg in dunkin egg is not bothered by
like a really hot summer day
um in the tv show some targaryens are
straight up immune to fire daenerys gets
immolated several times
just breathed in fire and she's unharmed
and unburnt several times
and when viserys is burned to death by
molten gold daenerys says he was not a
true dragon
fire cannot kill a dragon so it seems
that in the show some targaryens but not
all targaryens are fireproof whereas in
the books targaryens are not fireproof
but they are generally resistant to heat
i mean like holding your hand over a
candle flame i mean you can do that like
i don't think this necessarily means
that viserys is like fireproof but um
yes it is an interesting and provocative
thing to do and i think it sort of
raises that question of like is viserys
a true dragon can vaseris be burnt and i
tend to think that the answer is no well
it is i i think the viserys can be burnt
like metaphorically if not literally
like metaphorically i think touching the
flame is about like getting close to
fire and getting close to power
um and i think that viserys in some ways
does not succeed when he gets close to
power so yeah i think that is sort of
what they might be going for
metaphorically with that
i like that this scene took place in
front of the skull of balerion the black
dread who was the largest and biggest
and baddest targaryen dragon who who was
so large that his shadow would would
throw entire towns into darkness when
bellerion flew over them valerion was
the only living creature who had seen
valyria
which was the old empire of the
dragonlords before it was destroyed in
the doom of valyria
that's what viserys was making that
little model of apparently is it's a
model of the old empire of valyria the
city of valyria at the center of the
empire and belarion
came from valyria he's possibly the
oldest living creature in the world at
least he was until he died in the uh
fire and blood book a long time ago
there was a targaryen princess called
aeria targaryen and she flew off on
belaryon but she was too young to
control balerion and blaerion apparently
seemingly flew to valyria the the burned
and charred remains of valyria after it
had been destroyed in the doom
um and some really scary mysterious
messed up stuff happened to valerion and
urea in the book um it seems as though
there are these monstrous magical
terrifying things that now live in
valyria and um
bellerion saw that went back to his home
again so there's all sorts of cool
mysteries about that stuff and of course
you know valerion is interesting for
viserys because you know viserys
was a dragon rider vasaris rode the
biggest baddest targaryen dragon
but then balerion died of old age and
viseros now says that viserys now says
that like we can't control the dragons
we should never have trifled with the
dragons the idea that we control the
dragons is an illusion and so viserys is
very very aware of the danger of dragons
and like the whole book fire and blood
is just full of examples of dragons
killing zillions of people burning
castles eating people
fighting each other like dragons are a
terrifying destructive force and that's
something that we saw in the original
game of thrones show as well
um
so you know and i think that again
that's a metaphor for power and the
inherent dangers of power and that's
what the iron throne symbolizes as well
it's it's a it's a pile of swords that
cuts you if you sit on it versera says
that it's the most dangerous chair in
the realm so it's all about the dangers
of power thanks for the super chat from
musa who says thoughts on the ambiguity
of the heir for a day statement
yeah so after
the death of
emma and emma's baby balon we see daemon
having a orgy in a brothel and mazzaria
prompts daemon to speak
and he sort of toasts the dead baby
balon and otto says that daemon said
that balon was the heir for a day and
viserys gets really angry because it
seems like daemon is mocking
viserys's dead baby
um and it's interesting that we don't
actually see daemon personally say
uh air for a day
um
i guess there's kind of some ambiguity
there but like viserys confronts daemon
and said like hey did you say this
mocking stuff about my baby
and daemon doesn't deny it so i think
that he did say it um but it's
interesting that otto hightower is the
one who brings this to viserys and says
hey your brother prince daemon said this
[ __ ] up thing about your dead baby
um and you can definitely see that as
otto deliberately trying to undermine
daemon and viserys's relationship
because otto and daemon are political
rivals otto does not want daemon to get
the throne
so i think that otto was kind of
creating conflict between daemon and
viserys and he succeeds and viserys
sends daemon away
so um otto is a pretty conniving
machiavellian dude for sure and it's
interesting the role that mazaria plays
in that as well
um thanks for
the
super chat from seren who says emma was
an aaron but they gave her targaryen
hair that's because emma's mother um
was a targaryen in the books thanks for
the super chat from colin who says i'm
really excited about this show i'm sure
that the long term song of ice and fire
story will have a really cool ending and
nobody will be mad that is why i don't
love the prophecy thing because it
reminds us of season 8 episode 3 the
long night
i thought it's funny that there are
these sexy tapestries around the red
keep
in this scene you can see
uh
there's these tapestries there and
there's a tapestry over here of a bunch
of people having sex and that's just
like in people's
bedrooms there's just like these sexy
tapestries
and in interviews uh alison and
rhaenyra's actors were saying
that uh some of these tapestries depict
humans having sex with dragons
which is interesting uh because in the
books like there are references to you
know the valyrians uh who the targaryens
and the velaryons descend from the
valyrians believed that they were
literally descended from dragons like
some valyrians actually like had sex
with dragons and that's why valyrians
and targaryens have the blood of the
dragon and they have this bond with
dragons because they are blood related
uh and there's also hints in the books
about the valyrians
performing blood magic and creating
experimental chimeras and monsters that
are multiple species bred together uh
it's possible that dragons themselves
were created from wyverns which are
these natural sort of reptile creatures
um and by experimenting on the wyverns
they created dragons so it might have
been like literally just like boning a
dragon but it might have been some kind
of
blood magic dark sorcery that was done
by the ancient valyrians to
create
dragons and to create this blood magical
connection between targaryens and their
dragons and that's why only the
valyrians are able to control dragons
um
and this you know tapestry that includes
humans having sex with dragons might be
a can a nod to that i mean there's also
stuff about how you know the starks and
the people of the north and the first
men have this unique ability to warg and
to skin change and to control animals
like our bran stark does uh and it is
possible that that is the result of
similar magic or similar interbreeding
between the starks and animals or the
starks and children of the forest or the
starks and white walkers and there's all
sorts of
arcane mysteries there for sure uh
thanks for the super chat from ethan who
says how many seasons will this go for
uh the showrunners have said three or
four seasons for this story
um i like how they played the rhaenyra
emma relationship like this is something
that isn't really in the books we don't
hear much at all about emma in the book
uh but rainier is really showing us this
connection that she has with her mother
before she dies and sees how this
horrible world treats women and her
mother in particular and that creates
context for rhaenyra's political
ambitions
thanks for the super chat from aj who
says wouldn't dunk an egg be a better
spin-off after house of the dragon uh i
think they should finish the book series
first before they start adapting duncan
egg
uh i like how they had this moment where
rhaenyra was talking to emma and
uh emma was saying you've got to be a
noble lady you've got to produce babies
for men because that's the role of noble
ladies
whereas rhaenyra says i don't want to
produce babies i'd rather serve as a
knight and ride to battle and glory and
that's a lot like what arya stark says
in season one of game of thrones and in
the books when she tells ned that's not
me i don't want to be a wife i don't
want to be a noble lady
um i want to have adventures and travel
the world uh and explore and so that
rejection of gender roles is something
that arya and rhaenyra share and i think
it's also a similarity that rhaenyra has
with cersei
because cersei's story is very much
about how frustrated and angry she is
that she isn't able to have power in the
way that a man would
um i really liked how they introduced
viserys by like him telling a joke like
the first time we tell viserys he says
uh
so i said to him i believe you might be
looking up the wrong end and he's like
eating food and just hanging out and
laughing and like that you know viserys
is just this sociable fun guy
um and that's a contrast to a lot of the
serious political players uh it also was
sort of reminiscent to king bobby b in
season one of thrones
um
i
[Music]
like yeah i like the characterization of
corliss and otto and the emphasis on
valyria
i thought that this scene where daemon
gave rainier a gift was quite
interesting the way it was shot and
framed like i thought that daemon looked
quite possessive of rhaenyra the way
that he you know put the necklace on her
uh and this is stuff that's drawn from
the books like damon gave gifts to
rhaenyra and they had this closeness and
i thought i quite liked the way that was
done and how they introduced the
valyrian steel necklace
um it's really interesting that in this
scene
alison and rhaenyra are in the
winterfell godswood and sorry the red
keep godswood
because a lot of noble families and a
lot of castles most of them have god's
words which is where you go to worship
the old gods because the original
uh religion of the first men in westeros
was to worship the old gods which you do
by worshiping at a weirwood tree a heart
tree in the godswood and then the andals
came and they brought the faith of the
seven which is like catholicism and it
sort of overtook and replaced the old
gods and the first men a lot of the
weirwood trees were cut down and burned
by the andals
and now westeros is in this situation
where most of the houses follow
the seven
but some of the houses especially in the
north follow the first man and the old
gods in the books there is no weirwood
in
the red keep god's word i think it's an
oak tree that is the
heart tree now
uh but it's interesting that there's a
weirwood here so you know i guess that
might just be
they're trying to give us a sense of
similarity um to the show because you
know we saw the winterfell
uh heart tree quite a lot in season one
like we saw it in some of the opening
scenes of the show
when ned stark and catelyn um had that
scene in the in the winterfell godswood
so maybe they're just sort of trying to
draw a parallel there but it's an
interesting change to add that and i
wonder if it might go anywhere
um
i liked rainier is lying that she wants
to fly on dragons see the wonders of the
world and eat only cake
uh
i liked this sort of recurring thing
about the wounds on viserys from the
iron throne because like the idea that
the throne is continually cutting him
suggests that he's not handling power
well it suggests that there's something
rotten in the state of denmark you know
like there's something wrong here um
about viserys's rule
i thought it was really interesting that
in the conversation between viserys and
emma
emma said oh
she made a joke that she's like oh maybe
i'll hatch an actual dragon maybe i'll
give birth to a dragon
which is interesting because the
targaryens actually have a long history
of giving birth to babies that have
dragon-like features
there are
babies born to targaryens who have
dragon wings and tails and scales like
uh some of maegor targaryen's children
and daenerys uh in the books gives birth
to this stillborn baby rhaego none of
these like dragon babies have survived
they're all like described as deformed
and and twisted and stuff um but it it
keeps happening and
that might be due to the blood of the
dragon that the targaryens have um
and you know sometimes it's related
sometimes it is sort of like a hint of
like evil or something's wrong with this
character
um and so that sort of connects to emma
saying maybe i'll hatch a dragon and
it's like well maybe you will emma maybe
you will
i thought it was interesting and unusual
that they they drew some parallels
between
rhaenyra and visenya who was one of the
sister wives of uh aegon the conqueror
they they said that you know we already
have a visenya
um
and comparing rhaenyra to her is kind of
interesting because visenya was a
warrior woman she was possibly a little
bit of a sorceress she was very
um intense kind of
a bit evil i would say viserys was
visenya was um
so that was an interesting parallel to
make they also sort of contradicted
themselves when rhaenyra was saying to
allison that she wants emma's baby to be
a male whereas emma in this scene says
that rhaenyra wants uh emma's baby to be
a
female
maybe rainier is just saying different
things to different people i don't know
um i require coffee in a super chat says
is viserys's joke the punchline to
tyrion's joke because yeah in the um
in the game of thrones show tyrion tells
a joke about i brought a honeycomb and a
jackass into a brothel and we never get
to hear the uh punchline so could the
punchline be
you're looking in the wrong end uh which
is what sarah says in this scene i don't
know maybe
you might be looking up the wrong end
could that connect to the joke about the
honeycomb and the jackass
maybe maybe we're just gonna get like
different fragments of this joke
throughout the shows i don't know
uh thanks for the super chat from sir
akimandud who says what's the story with
cole and how do you think he'll play a
part with the princess
i don't want to give any spoilers
because you know the whole story is in
the book um but i thought it was kind of
interesting that they said that kristen
cole is dornish like in the
books he's from the dornish marches
which is like sort of the the
borderlands between like the stormlands
and the reach and dawn um and i thought
it was weird how like they looked at him
and they're like oh wow he's dornish and
it's like is that a dornish face like i
guess he has sort of like dark hair and
darkish features i guess i don't know
um but yeah he's like a low-born dude
he's got a lot to prove he's got a lot
of advancement to make uh he's come to
the attention of the royal family so
there's a lot of potential for
advancement there and um he's clearly um
made an impression on uh rhaenyra and
alicent
so uh yeah be interesting to see what he
gets up to
i
really liked emma's discomfort with
viserys's um ambitions like vasara said
oh i had a dream that our son was born
with a crown on his head and and emma is
like god spammy like the last thing that
my baby needs is a crown um and there's
this sense of these long-suffering women
who are being dragged along with the
ambitions of men
um which i enjoyed like like so much of
this story is just about the folly of
ambition and the dangers of wanting
power
and you know amon's brothers who were
killed by their dreams is an example of
that
um i thought damon was really funny
throughout um i thought you know in
these scenes where he was on the small
council just just provoking otto and
just stirring [ __ ]
and you know viserys tries to
lay down the law viserys tells him
you know if you do this again it will be
answered and then damon just gives this
sort of smirk like that is the cheeky
smirk when he's being told off like he's
such a rebellious little sly teenager
is how i see his performance um and he
says all understood your grace but like
he doesn't seem as though he really
cares all that much about viserys's
instructions
um i thought it was interesting that
miss masaria uh daemon's lover
suggested that she get a blonde maiden
for damon to have sex with
isn't it interesting that daemon has a
sexual interest in blond maidens
specifically
um i
think that the whole concept of summer
nights is relevant to the nights in this
tournament when like rainier when
rhaenys was saying that you know these
are all men who have never been in a
real war they're all naive and it's very
similar to a conversation that catelyn
has with brienne in book two
when you know brienne is all caught up
in the splendor and the glory and the
ambition of renly's camp when renly is
trying to take the throne in book two
and catelyn says that these are summer
nights they have no idea about the
realities the horrible realities of
violence and war and winter and death
and so there's this sort of naivety that
is going to be followed by violent
disillusionment uh it's definitely a
sense that we get here
thanks for the super chat from nick who
says that the godswood are typically in
the north which is cold we know martin
worked with the showrunners winds of
winter christmas 2022 confirmed i i
think it adds up i can't disagree with
your logic the winds of winter any day
now
winds of winter is the upcoming next
book in the unfinished book series
thanks for the super chat from amy who
says do you think they may show aegon
the first in this series i mean aegon's
been dead for 100 years so you know he's
probably not in a condition to appear on
screen they might have flashbacks to him
i suppose um but maybe they're trying to
keep their powder dry in case they ever
want to make an aegons conquest tv show
if past the dragon is successful they
said they might cover other time periods
maybe they could make a show about
aegon's conquest i think that could
potentially be interesting
thanks for the super chat from ethan who
says do you think there's any
correlation between the mad king saying
burn them all and him knowing about the
threat from the north yeah so there is
some speculation that like the reason
why the mad king was shouting burned
them all in his madness before his death
was that he was actually having visions
of the white walkers and um he was
trying to say burn the white walkers to
me that feels a bit convoluted
um
but in some ways it sort of fits like i
think some people speculated that bran
stark might be giving the mad king
heiress those visions um and so there's
sort of this tragic accident in like
bran stark causing the mad king's
madness but like the mad king had been
mad for a long time
like gradually and there's no mention of
him having those sorts of dreams
uh but i mean certainly like this whole
thing about the targaryens knowing about
the white walkers it does
invite us to reconsider a lot of the
targaryens throughout the timeline so
you know
that that might provoke some
reconsideration but i mean it's already
in the books they've just made it less
mysterious which yeah i don't love
um
i like
how
otto [ __ ] up in putting taemon in
charge of the city watch
um because like viserys points out in
these scenes that you know originally
daemon was the master of laws but then
otto said he shouldn't be the master of
laws because he's a tyrant and then so
they made him the master of coin and
then otto said he shouldn't be the
master of coin because he's spending all
this money so then otto suggested he'd
be put on the city watch and then now
he's causing a ruckus as the commander
of the city watch and so like otto is
constantly trying to like remove daemon
from power but daemon always finds a way
to create havoc
with whatever position he is in and you
know otto sort of
[ __ ] up by putting damon in charge of
the gold cloaks because now he's
arguably as powerful as ever he's got
like quite a loyal force of these
well-armed gold cloaks who appear
fiercely loyal to daemon he calls them
his hounds and they are cheering for him
and he buys out brothels for them so
daemon has power military power in the
heart of king's landing as a result of
this so um well i guess he did he's been
sort of sent from king's landing now so
maybe he no longer has that power
thanks for the super chat from lucas who
says dragon show good thanks for the
super chat from alan and from secularis
who says what do you think the story is
with the iron thrones appearance in the
show is it an attempt to make it more
like the books or is it a visual
allusion to the tags adding more swords
to the pile yeah so like originally in
the original game of thrones show the
iron throne was quite small compared to
how it looks now it looks very grand now
in house of the dragon it's got lots of
swords um i think that you know like it
could plausibly make sense that you know
when aegon the conqueror uh created the
iron throne 300 years before game of
thrones uh it was huge because there was
lots of swords and maybe like over time
the targaryens removed some of the
swords and made it a bit smaller made it
a bit more practical until by the time
of game of thrones season one
the throne is much smaller indeed um i
think that's like a perfectly reasonable
like story justification for
how it all happened
um because this is how the throne looks
in the game of thrones tv show the
original show um whereas in the books it
it just has always been massive um
and the idea is that it's this monstrous
symbol of war and danger and power and
the so and the sword of damocles you
ever hear the legend of the
story of the sword of damocles which is
like there's this king who sits on the
throne and above the the king's head is
a sword hanging by a thread above his
head and the idea is that that shows
that at any time the sword could drop on
you at any time if you're in power you
could be killed at any moment power is
inherently dangerous so i think of the
iron throne as like sort of a bigger
version of the sword of damocles the
swords of damocles forged into one i've
also heard in interviews and stuff that
the house of the dragon throne um all of
these swords some of them are taken from
the productions from the set departments
from the prop departments of other
hollywood fantasy shows like the
warcraft movie had a bunch of swords and
some of the swords from the warcraft
movie
are in this iron throne so like
in the same way that aegon the conqueror
made the iron throne
from the swords of his defeated enemies
they say that house of the dragon has
used the swords of rival fantasy shows
to forge its own power which is
symbolically fun and i'll note that the
lord of the rings
tv show is coming out in a week or two
so that is uh some say that as a rival
to the house of the dragon fantasy show
thanks for the super chat from sir aki
akiyama dude who says speaking of otto
do you think he's pimping his daughter
or is he just planting the seed alison
has something going on for sure so what
are otto's intentions in sending alice
and to go and visit king viserys in his
chambers well yeah you certainly can
question what otto's motivations are
there but i don't want to be spoiling
anything thanks for the super chat from
e who says the dreams of aegon feel like
a big revelation of a dream of spring
did they choose to show them now because
we might never get that book that is a
depressing thought like
maybe george knows that he'll never
finish the main books and so he's just
trying to put some of those ideas in
these tv shows instead maybe maybe on
some level but george
is saying that he's determined to finish
the series and we can only hope that he
will succeed in that
um so
i thought that the scene where viserys
spoke with daemon and then viserys
declared that he was disinheriting
daemon and making rhaenyra his heir
instead i thought that the way that they
played that was interesting because it
sort of made it seem as though
viserys was being impulsive in doing
that in the show um
sad damon um like
it it really seemed as though viserys
was
angered by
damon who who told viserys you are weak
you're weak viserys and then it's
immediately after that that that viserys
is visibly upset and so he immediately
says i'm disinheriting you i'm making
rainier of the air instead so
it's it seems like a very emotional in
the moment reaction as opposed to
something that he really thought about
carefully
um so you know acting impulsively for
matters of succession is obviously a
pretty dangerous thing to do but he does
also clearly have a lot of confidence in
rhaenyra um
but like you know how long has he had
that confidence because for so long he
was saying i'm gonna have a son i had a
prophetic dream i'm gonna have a baby
boy that's gonna be my heir but at the
same time he was having rhaenyra as his
cupbearer at council he always has loved
rhaenyra and he always has kept rhaenyra
close so that she can learn politics
from the council so
sort of goes both ways um he he clearly
has had respect for rhaenyra for a long
time
even as he originally was preferring a
male heir
um
i thought that in the in the inside the
episode they talk about how viserys's
choice to make rainier the heir is
partly out of guilt for the death of
emma his wife
uh on his orders
having her cut open so you know i guess
he might see rhaenyra as sort of
embodying emma's legacy uh and for that
reason he wants her on the throne
um and yeah like we also see
viserys cutting himself on the throne
immediately after disinheriting daemon
and making rhaenyra the heir
immediately cutting himself after
changing the succession which again
suggests that he might not be handling
power well
um
any other questions you want me to
answer
uh i think that we've covered most of
what happened in this episode
we got a glimpse of little elena
valarion lana and lenore are going to
become relevant characters later on
um
i thought the funeral scene was
interesting because it was daemon
who speaks kindly and sensitively to
rhaenyra like daemon is usually seen as
a bit of a chaotic dick bag uh but in
this case he's saying like hey rhaenyra
like your father needs you like he's
trying to offer a bit of comfort and
it's interesting to see that damon is
the one to do that you know like he is
violent and chaotic but he also
shows concern for people's feelings
sometimes at least rain ears he's
clearly someone who is sensitive to rain
near his feelings they're really trying
to humanize daemon a lot in ways that he
wasn't in the books so much
uh what else is happening in the chat
uh i don't know what the little balls
are on the small council table i think
it's just a symbol of like we're here to
chat we're here to have a meeting
r says the targaryen hair looks so good
uh first time we saw the blackfire sword
yeah so there is this ancient valyrian
steel sword uh which is like the symbol
of targaryen kingship and so we get to
see it in this scene with viserys the
location of the blackfyre sword is a
mystery in the time of the main game of
thrones books 200 years later um and
there's a lot of speculation that
blackfyre the sword might turn up again
some other time it's really important
who has blackfyre the sword because it
is seen as like whoever has that sword
must be the rightful king um and
similarly with dark sister which is like
the other super important ancestral
targaryen valyrian steel sword which is
wielded by daemon so it's a good it's a
good idea to keep an eye on those
valyrian steel blades
um
are we going to release the on the next
episode trailer
uh
i haven't got it right here we can
all right do you guys maybe we should do
like spoiler corner should we do like a
spoiler corner
um thanks for the super chat from lord
stark who says what's your opinion on
viserys forcibly choosing his son over
his wife
um the episode implied only one could
survive but the creators said they would
die regardless yeah i i thought i mean
it's very important isn't it like was
viserys choosing
to
kill emma to try and save the baby
or was emma definitely gonna die anyway
so you might as well try and save the
baby you know like yeah in the inside
the episode ryan condell the showrunner
said
emma was gonna die anyway but um
if there was any chance of emma
surviving that makes it more [ __ ] up
to cut her open and kill her
so i yeah i agree with you that it
seemed a little bit ambiguous in the
episode but the showrunner seems to say
that um it was emma was gonna die
regardless thanks for the super chat
from sir who says i love your work keep
it up which of the game of thrones books
is your favorite so far i think my
favorite game of thrones book is a storm
of swords the third book in the main
series uh mostly because of the tyrion
stuff i think tyrion is
probably the best character
in game of thrones and i think that his
sort of climactic confrontation with
tywin is really great and amazing
um and a great fulfillment of that whole
arc
um thanks for the super chat from osmond
who says that the valyrian was a really
nice touch
uh thanks for super chat from basically
a god um who asked us sort of a spoilery
question yeah we won't do the spoilery
stuff i think we're gonna
wrap up this live stream
shortly
um
maybe we'll just watch the on the next
episode thing first so if you don't want
to see the inside the episode the on the
next episode trailer we're going to
watch that do a little bit of more
spoilery
speculation so if you're worried about
spoilers i suggest that you
uh
leave we're going to wrap up the live
stream shortly and first we're going to
watch the on the next episode
so we're going to go to youtube and
we're going to search they didn't put it
on hbo max so
um house of the dragon trailer next
episode
this is going to be really easy to find
isn't it for sure okay weeks ahead
trailer let's
oh my god let's watch that together
shall we
um
all right so we're gonna watch the next
episode's trailer so if you don't want
to see that you might want to avoid this
let's check it out
i've seen most of this footage
already
dragon keepers
oh okay the prince was promised that is
the prophecy
they're talking more about the prophecy
that's interesting we might learn more
okay i'm not expecting that
oh what what what seed is that is that
where's that meant to be is that high
tide
the velaryon no that can't be high tide
i don't know which castle that is
maybe it is high tide because that's
cordless there
you go the new character caraxies
causing a ruckus
older rainy arrow
dragon pit
painted table prague scrub feeder
so as you can see there's going to be
conflict between alison and rhaenyra
big santa claus outfit that's fun
kristen cole
cat's poor dagger
true true that's what viserys doesn't
want to do
whoa
is that viserys like attacking damon
with a knife
wow
that's that's intense nothing like that
in the books
who are these kids
yeah i think i know which characters
those are they look very strong
cyrax
right here
war in the stepstones call us and damon
doing a war for fun
vega the biggest and oldest dragon in
the world
yeah sure that looks like that looks
like fire and blood to me they are being
pretty faithful to the books like
they've got to make some stuff up uh
because the books are just a summary
it's just a cliff notes but um
yeah i mean generally i'm pretty happy
with this show i think it looks good
um
[Music]
it's going to be interesting like later
on when there are certain mysteries and
there are certain important events that
are ambiguous in the books that the show
is going to have to clarify and show
what really happened so um
that'll be interesting to see
um
thanks for superchat from entropy who
likes the idea of a spoiler section
lewis says what were your thoughts on
the targaryen sigil on the master of
ceremonies for the jousting fight error
what was wrong with the targaryen sigil
like he was just being like a herald and
like a representative of the targaryens
right like it's so yeah like this guy
you're talking about this guy
i i don't see nothing wrong with that
the sigil it's i mean the fact that it's
black it's like a blackfire sigil no
he's just representing the targaryens i
think that's fine
um
disappearing bunny in the super chat
says damon was offered a girl with
silver hair yeah so to get a bit
spoilery and again if you don't want any
spoilers for season one i'm gonna drop a
moderate spoiler for season one
um so damon and rhaenyra have a
relationship later on uncle and niece
yeah targaryen incest um and yeah i do
think that makes it interesting that
missouri
suggests that daemon have sex with a
blonde maiden it suggests that daemon
has some under ongoing sexual interest
in blonde maidens
and of course rhaenyra is a blonde
maiden so
it creates this creepy sort of like
sexual grooming thing like damon is all
like sweet on rhaenyra and bringing her
gifts uh at the same time that he has a
sexual interest in blonde maidens so
it's kind of gross the way daemon is um
you know treating rhaenyra like this
perhaps with the intention of eventually
having a sexual relationship with her
thanks for the super jet from ethan who
is refreshed by the decent writing
thanks to the super chat from sam who
says so when are we getting a time jump
next step or are we going back and forth
i think it's going to be mostly linear
from now on um we're going to go
forwards in time
um
and there are going to be
according to interviews there are going
to be multiple time jumps most of them
are going to be like a few years but
there's going to be like a 10 year time
jump when we go from
uh young rhaenyra to
uh adult rhaenyra and allison
um so yeah i don't know when that
happens in the season but like they're
already sort of messing with the
timeline and like simplifying it because
like even the events of just this
episode like emma dying in childbirth uh
the the tournament which is in
maidenpool i think it's the equivalent
of the maidenpool tournament but they
hold it in king's landing in the show um
and rhaenyra being named air like
there's years in between those events in
the book like the book is like this
thing happened on this year then this
thing happened the next year and then
the next year this thing happened
whereas in this episode they've like
compressed um all of the events into
what feels like you know a week or two
uh which i think makes sense you know
just to simplify the story we don't want
to make a complicated timeline i think
those are all
good choices
um
i'm yeah so i'm curious to see what else
they change what else they bring in
um but overall i'm
pretty optimistic about this show i
think that it'll be fun for like the
book nerds i don't know if the casual
watchers are going to be super into it
but
i think for book nerds it's going to be
a fun time and we're going to make a
explained video to
cover each
like more fully summarize and analyze
each episode uh that'll come out around
thursday or friday
and we're going to keep doing live
streams immediately after each episode
10 15 pm eastern time sundays so like
and subscribe might want to follow on
twitter um
but
yeah we won't do too much like like it's
weird because all the spoilers are out
there like anyone can read fire and
blood anyone can i mean even like the
world of ice and fire has a very short
uh and succinct summary of everything
that's gonna happen in this show uh it's
all on the wikis as well
um
but i don't know i don't really wanna
sit here and just tell you everything
that's gonna happen
um
i think it's gonna be more fun
to go along with the ride week by week
so all right we're going to
wrap up this live stream
there's going to be
videos coming it's going to be more
streams
and uh it's going to be a good time
thanks for watching everybody i'll leave
this live stream up on the channel um at
least until the explained video comes
out just so it's easy to find but i
think afterwards it'll go on the
podcast channel so you might like to
subscribe to the alt shift x podcast on
youtube or spotify or your podcast app
might possibly do some like chats with
other
game of thronesy
creator people throughout the season if
we have time hopefully on the podcast so
it might be worth subscribing
uh thanks for checking those links in
the chat shubert there is also a patreon
uh patreon supporters can get a little
bit of
access to some little sneak peeks and
chats in the discord early updates early
access to videos since it's so time
sensitive it'll probably just be like a
few hours patrons will get videos early
because like you know i don't want to
wait a day because these videos are only
like up to date for a short amount of
time but uh thanks to everyone who
supports on patreon thanks to everyone
who watches happy to have you all here
happy to chat always happy to hear your
thoughts
and uh we'll be back soon
have a good one cheers
[Music]
you